hello everyone i would like to welcome
those uh participants who have just
joined we will be starting in more five
minutes from now we are waiting for
everyone else to join as well
and meanwhile we begin with the today's
session it would be nice if you can put
in the chat box about yourself
uh it could include your educational
background and also something about your
research interest
thank you
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for the first session of
genomics data analysis
this is an online bioinformatics
training program that will provide an
in-depth overview of concepts and
analytical tools used to study genomic
variations
the program is designed to introduce
students clinicians and researchers to
the role of and the applications of
genomic data analysis to study genomic
variation and apply genomics in
translational sciences to improve
diagnostic accuracy predict which drugs
are likely to be effective in patients
and also contribute to the monitoring
treatment and diseases in individuals
and populations
today we will discuss about the course
structure expectations and the intended
outcomes of this particular program
we will discuss about the applications
of bioinformatics and also discuss about
view of the coursework that you can
definitely go through including
introduction to bioinformatics
we will discuss about examples in
biomedical research
pharma r d and agriculture as well
each week participants will meet online
to discuss various aspects of ngs data
processing genomic data analysis and
interpretation
after the first introductory lectures
participants will have the opportunity
to get guidance and also work on curated
data sets or develop independent
projects that leverage the tools and
concepts covered in this program
i would first of all like to introduce
myself my name is sunalika ray and i'm
the omixlogic community manager
and i'm and i'm responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of a bioinformatics community
that is managed by prime biotech
amix logic programs are a result of
close collaboration between
pine biotech and innovative big data
analytics company which is based in the
us and numerous academic institutions
that have participated in content
evaluation curriculum review and project
design
and as a result the omixlogic programs
have been thoroughly tested around the
world and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes for students with minimal
bioinformatics background including
biology and biomedical study majors as
well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science and
biomedical research
so before we start with today's session
i would like to introduce us
as already told we are a u.s based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
our training programs are running in
five different regions with over 15 000
plus users around the world who have
completed the training programs
the programs follow a project-based
learning approach using research grade
tools to analyze data from top peer
reviewed journals
the training has been completed by 15
000 participants from 162 countries in
over 300 workshops for six different
specialization drugs which include
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omics data analysis
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations developing a training
program for research-oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
we will combine online sessions
self-guided training study materials and
practical assignments as well for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective in these training programs
which are known as omixlogic
i take the honor to introduce the
founders and the team members of the
company
dr alfred trobel comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one office major project
is the establishment of bioinformatics
research center the tobacco center that
has been at the core of what we do and
throughout the program you will get the
guidance and go through this uh the
server as well
dr leonard brodsky is the director of
the topper bioinformatics research
center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people who are mentioned
here on the right julia panoff is an
expert bioinformatician avitovsky leads
the development of the platform dr
harpreet has an expertise in the
application of statistical machine
learning techniques and biomedical data
and looks after the curriculum
development
dr mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician and has multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
he has been developing collaborations
with universities as a mentor and
project lead for unexotic training and
research fellowship
dr raghavendran is an accomplished
computational biologist with an
experience in large scale analysis of
multi-omics data and data science
methods in precision oncology and
protein dna structural bioinformatics
we will today also hear from dr
raghavendran and mr elia brocksky
so let's start by signing up on the
learn.ormixlogic portal this educational
portal will help you get started on your
bioinformatics journey and also
throughout the course you will be given
directions to access the t bioinfo
platform for bioinformatics processing
and analysis of transcriptomics data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipeline
the different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections of this
multi-omics platform
now to proceed with before we go ahead
and sign up on the omixlogic learn
portal i just quickly like to launch a
cool so that we can
know the audience who have
joined this particular session and also
get some knowledge about their
backgrounds
dr mohit can you launch the poll for me
i can see you have also joined the
session
and meanwhile let me share my screen
okay so uh i am now going to put the
link of the portal in the chat box
thank you so much dr mohit
so my first question is
what is your educational background do
you have are you a graduate or a post
graduate or a person with the background
in phd or post stock
and my second question is don't know
about your research interest
so what is your research in trust is it
infectious diseases neuroscience
precision medicine
agriculture or space comics
and my third question is
what outcome do you seek after joining
the program
is it a specialized training that you
want to go through
or a research project
so we'll have this poll up for more 30
seconds and it would be nice if you all
could answer the poll
and for those who have answered the poll
i'm sending in the link to learn dot
omics logic portal in the chat box
if you have already signed up on the
portal then please drop a one or yes in
the chat box for our knowledge
and if you are new uh
and join the session for the very first
time and have not yet signed up then
please go to the link and let's create
an account for yourself
so i'll just do a quick demo so that you
can see how you have to sign up just
click on the login button on the top
right
and this will redirect you
to a
uh
to an interface like this
now you either click on create an
account for yourself put your mail
address create a password for yourself
put your details and create an account
or you can also create an account by
simply
using any of your google accounts or
facebook accounts or other social media
accounts
so i'm awaiting the responses in the
chat box
thank you karl maxx
those who have signed up please let me
know in the chat box so that we can
proceed further
[Music]
thank you sir
yes so after answering the poll ratio it
would be nice if you could go on to the
portal that is learn.amixlogic.com
and create an account for yourself
because this will help you go through
the resources various resources that we
are going to discuss today and work with
them
okay so i can see a lot of you have
already signed up and are signing up
those who have completed their sign up
the next step for them is to complete
their profile so now to complete your
profile you need to click on this mail
address of yours in the menu bar and
this will redirect you to the profile
section
you need to ensure that you have an
updated profile picture your name is in
the title case because for each and
every coursework that you complete on
the portal you will be uh given the
certificate and the certificate will
have the same name as you uh type in uh
your profile so please make sure that
your name is not in capitalized format
or
small alphabets it should be entitled
case
also please link in your social media
accounts
so that we can feature your profile
based on your progress and also have a
brief bio about yourself that could
include your educational background your
research interest what you want to work
on etc
also for every course work that you
complete you will get certain points and
these points are going to take you from
a beginner level to an expert level
so you can see
uh your courses that you complete your
progress here in the profile tab with
the points that you get on the
achievements that you have completed and
also those who have already joined this
particular program genomics data
analysis
please make sure that you have the badge
of genomics in your profile this will
ensure that you have the access to the
program page i'll just shortly take you
to uh to the program page and show you
the relevance of the same also you need
to ensure that you have a starter
subscription active that will give you
an access to all the course works on the
portal and if you don't have the batch
or the starter subscription then you
please need to tell me so that i can
give you the same
okay so now coming to the program page
so this is the program page of the
program
uh for which we are here today that is
genomics data analysis
now on this program page you will find
the session schedule
of the program where you can see first
of all the days for which each and every
session has been scheduled also the
topics that will be covered um in each
of these dates and the associated online
resources
now with each and every session you need
to go through some resources that we
have mentioned here
you need to these all resources are
hyperlinked as a part of the session
completion you have to go through these
lessons as well and make sure that you
complete them before you actually click
on the complete session icon that will
come up here after each session
i'm going to upload the uh recording of
the of each and every session as we
completed here on the program page
itself so to revise the session or go
through it once again or let's say you
could not join the live session you were
busy somewhere else you can definitely
refer to the program page and go through
the recording at your own pace and
complete the resources as well and then
you just click on the complete session i
can
it's very important that you all the
program participants should have the
access to the program page because by
completing each and every session that
is mentioned here on the program page
after you do so for all the sessions you
will be able to get your certificate
towards the end of
the program towards the completion of
the program
so that was the relevance of the program
page and before we actually get started
with uh today's session i'll just take
two more minutes and assist you all on
how you can navigate through the various
courses that are present on the
learn.org logic portal and then we
hear from australia brotsky and dr
raghav and get started with the session
so once you are here on the portal you
will see various categories here so if
you click on the courses uh tab in the
menu bar this will redirect you to all
the coursework that is there on the
portal
now coming to these section of tags that
you can see here on the right side
just by clicking on the tags you you can
filter out which category you would like
to
explore and learn more about so if you
just click on course all the courses
that we have on the portal will just
come up and you can go through them and
explore more
now throughout the
program we are going to give you
directions on uh on like which and how
which particular lesson you have to go
through and what resources you have to
go through and what are exactly you have
to practice and get some hands on so i'm
just giving you an idea of how you can
navigate on the portal we'll be giving
you more detailed uh
ideas uh when we just go along each and
every session
and if you want to have a look at the
projects now these are some example
projects which will help you understand
the applications of a particular key
concept let's say that you went through
in the course work and will help you
understand how the concepts that you
learn in a particular course work could
be applied to answer a particular
research problem or a research question
in hand so these are the list of example
projects that you can explore and learn
from
also then you have various
specialization scenes that you can
specifically pick and
go ahead so if you just click on project
and then click on genomics so you will
get all the example projects that are
related to the specialized
specialized field of genomics and yes
and definitely you can pick the field
and explore more so that was the easiest
way of how you can navigate on the
portal so now i would like to pass on
this session to mr elia brodsky to uh
let us get started with the uh session
and learn more about genomic data
analysis and why is it important and
what is the relevance so over to you mr
alia
so nanika please make me co-host so i
can share my screen
yes yeah you are a co-host now
thank you
all right so
uh great to have all of you joined today
i'm going to briefly cover some of the
topics that we're going to be discussing
for this program on genomic data
analysis so
the
objective of this program is really to
cover a broad overview of different
types of topics provide you with the
methods that you can practically apply
to analyze
the data genomic sequencing data but
also importantly to understand
how it is can be applied to a variety of
different project examples and try it
out on your own so hopefully by the time
that you complete this program you will
understand
what the terminology means especially
when you read the papers you will also
be able to practically have experience
and know where to start your project how
the different stages are connected to
each other how to interpret this and
have a meaningful discussion with your
peers or with others about genomic data
analysis and interpretation but today i
want to briefly start from the very
beginning later on i will show you where
you can find a lot of the information
that we cover in today's session but i i
will just take a few minutes to talk
about some of the basics because we
typically assume that everybody is on
the same page but you know a lot of
people just by not understanding certain
types of
terms or maybe concepts it's very
difficult to follow along
so what is dna code what do we know
about the dna code and what is it that
we still don't know what is there else
that we are trying to learn why why do
people continue to study genomic data
and try to interpret and understand what
this code means
so dna code especially when we talk
about eukaryotes and we talk about uh
you know people
we think of this code as a book of
recipes so it's organized in a specific
structure it has sentences
paragraphs paragraphs that are organized
into chapters and so really learning
this book and how to navigate and spot
these patterns is the basics of is the
basic approach of genomics so dna is
short for deoxyribonucleic acid
it's a long molecule that's composed of
two chains that coil around each other
and form this double helix that we all
know
and the code contains instructions
so these instructions are coded in the
human genome in about three billion base
pairs so it's very long not all of those
base pairs contain information that ends
up being translated into proteins
and similar approaches of
putting information into this code are
used by bacteria
viruses
you know enlarged organisms
multicellular organisms as well
so
the same approach the same code contains
directions or recipes for what we call
life
and life
is the condition that
sorry
that distinguishes animals and plants
from inorganic matter so what does life
give us it gives us the capacity for
growth
reproduction
functional activity and continual change
that precedes steps so when we talk
about life here you can see a really
nice animation or
actually not an animation a video where
a single you know small microorganism
and maybe even different kinds of
microorganisms are moving right and
that's really what distinguishes life
from these inorganic
uh
matter like rocks for example so
when we uh have these uh
you know the these um
recipes or these pieces of code
they are organized uh in a very tight uh
way by compressing this
long molecule
into a
very tightly compacted
kind of
you know nucleus and when cells divide
what happens is that
in the nucleus we have all of this dna
and when it divides uh we can see how
this dna is organized because it needs
to be unfolded
and so what we discover are these
strings that are inside and we can
actually see them so this is the process
of division and what you can see are
these chromosomes right so these
chromosomes are actually
you know string of dna
also packaged very tightly in these
you know specific shapes so these
chromosomes contain different genes each
one of our cells contains 23 pairs of
chromosomes one of the chromosomes comes
from our mother and the other from her
father
and the unique structure of chromosomes
keeps dna tightly wrapped around
spool-like proteins called histones
without such packaging dna molecules
would be too long to fit inside our
cells
so
when we think of this chromosome this
chromosome we can expand it and this is
what it looks like
so here's the actual dna this string
right here that is uh kind of coiled
around
these histones so if we continue and
unfold it you can see that
these are the histones and it's packaged
right around those histones
so
when we
speak about this code and what does this
code actually contain what instructions
does it contain so the product of the
code and the way that it interacts with
the environment is called a phenotyping
so a phenotype can describe a single
cell a tissue organ or the whole
organism phenotype of an organism might
include height size and activity and
phenotype of a cell might include
specific function size and morphology or
its shape
so the code which is packaged in this
molecule defines this phenotype right
defines first phenotype of the cell then
of the organ or the tissue and then of
the whole organism right and so the the
basis of this code is all about these
nucleotides so these nucleotides are
made up of a sugar called deoxyribose a
nitrogen containing base and a phosphate
group the nucleotides are joined to one
another in a chain by covalent bonds
that form between the sugar of one
nucleotide and the phosphate of the next
and the resulting
the the result of this structure is an
alternating sugar phosphate backbone so
each strand of dna molecule consists of
a sequence of bases that is
complementary to the base as an opposing
strand so when we say a base pair right
you will hear a lot when we speak about
genomics this term called base pair
nucleotide amino acid this is where it
comes from so a single
structure here is a base and the
connected
are base
pair this molecule can be read from both
sides you can see the three prime and
the five prime ends so you can read from
either side and this single base pair
represents some kind of a
you know a nucleotide so this nucleotide
we would refer to one of these adenine
guanine
inside the c
so to understand how this code works and
what is in this code as you all know
this is the famous starting point of the
human genome project you can see it was
published in the new york times on
tuesday june 27 2000 when they uh
announced that the this code of human
life is cracked by scientists right so
now all scientists understand how these
dna sequences that we can now read
are organized to inform us about life
what is life how does life function how
does it produce the phenotype
now today we are in 2021
21 years later so if that happened 21
years ago what else do we need to learn
about this
so it turns out
that simply reading the code and
annotating it is a much longer process
than the human project itself the human
project itself was focused on
understanding what is in the code
and they discovered that there's only
one to two percent of protein-coding
genes
the rest
are non-protein-coding genes and so we
have a lot of other types of information
that is in the dna
and we now know that there is there are
a lot of questions there are a lot of
additional things to understand about
the human genome about the dna how it is
organized and how it actually works and
it's a very complex
approach that people now take to study
individual specific regions of the dna
and try to understand what is the impact
of how this code is written to describe
life and describe phenotype
so
as we spoke dna is stored in the nucleus
organized in chromosomes and specific
regions are responsible for specific
functions some of the easiest regions to
read and understand their function are
what we call protein coding genes
there's a total of 22
500 protein coding genes but even that
number continues to change
protein coding genes are the sequences
that are used to produce proteins and
then they also have a specific structure
so when we think of this code working or
producing that phenotype the way it is
done is by dna
being transcribed into rna and then
being translated into proteins
so these proteins
that are produced from dna is
facilitated by several different
proteins it's a complex kind of a
translational process
that uh you know we we will study uh in
a little detail to understand exactly
how it works but the basic concept that
we need to understand is that the
individual nucleotides or base pairs
that we saw in the dna eventually had to
have to be converted into amino acids
which is what the proteins are made up
of and so when we think of protein
coding genes we're going to be looking
at sequences
dividing them up into triad codons
and then
looking at how those trinucleotide
codons sorry
and looking at what they mean how do
they function in terms of amino acids
so
the function of the rna polymerase is to
convert dna to rna and then the ribosome
of course converts the rna into protein
so the genome composition you know let's
just talk a little bit about how the
human genome is maybe different from
other genomes
the human genome is not the longest
genome you can see right here's the
human
uh grape for example is much longer not
much much longer but longer nevertheless
and
influenza for example
flu or covet we all know is the
thousands of nucleotides long as opposed
to the human
which really has
tens of thousands of genes
and billions of nucleotides so influenza
for example has 11 genes and uh you know
is somewhere about 20 000
nucleotides uh and that's how many genes
we have so here you can see what types
of genes do we actually have and you can
see that nine percent so almost 10 of
genes we don't even know what they are
but how do we know uh that a gene is a
gene so a gene is also organized in a
very specific way they're not just
sequences of nucleotides they have
upstream and downstream regulatory
sequences that control transcription
inside the gene sequence itself there
are codons and introns that undergo
splicing before a gene is translated
into a protein and the length of these
genes can vary significantly and so they
vary because they have these introns
that could be very long
so when we speak about translation like
we said the translation occurs as a
result of ribosomes so here you can see
this is a microscope image of unfolded
dna you can see that the ribosomes are
these large dots right here and that is
what they look like so what happens is
mrna gets it into the dna it gets into
the ribosome and the outside of this
ribosome we already have this protein
which is a sequence that is folded
and eventually forms a protein that
looks like this
so this protein this is actually two
different proteins bound together
because proteins now have a function
they interact with each other and so in
the context of genomic data analysis we
can look at every step of the way we can
look at the dna we can look at the
impact of this dna on transcription and
we can look at the impact of dna in
terms of translation and so the ultimate
goal of genomics is to integrate
multiple
aspects of this kind of data by looking
at
where the gene or genes are located in
terms of the chromosome
what do we know about the organization
of that gene and how that gene could be
translated into a protein so here you
can see that protein structure
and eventually to validate its function
through experiments so here you can see
this is the same protein this protein is
nm23h1 this is a protein that is
responsible for
control of metastasis or spreading in
cancer and you can see that its
structure is known because we have a
crystallized structure of the protein
but we also have studies that show how
this protein functions and we can
measure this in terms of
animal models
cell lines and compare and contrast how
it
works in in different variations
so when we talk about genomics in this
program we're going to be talking at
looking at data
to try to understand
what this data can tell us
about a particular phenotype and there
are several different ways that we're
going to be able to look at this we're
going to be looking at methods like
multiple sequence alignment variant
calling phylogenetic analysis we'll talk
about what types of mutations and
variations we can find which ones cause
a change at gene expression level which
ones cause the change at the protein
function level so we'll talk about all
of these things throughout this program
but the basis of this program is going
to be based on data and the data that we
now study to represent genomic variation
has evolved since the beginning of that
human genome and now we have thousands
and thousands of human genomes as well
as genomes that are representative of
pretty much a lot of organisms that you
can study so when you think of what you
can do with genomic data analysis once
you know how to analyze it you really
have a huge potential of understanding
you know validation of specific types of
variation that we can observe including
human disease in response to different
treatments and ultimately this trend
will continue so knowing and acquiring
the skills to analyze such data is a
critical skill that you will take away
with you to be able to contribute to the
continuous exploration and understanding
of how genomes work what do they encode
in terms of genes and how can those
genes be studied in terms of regulation
of these complex conditions like cancer
like infectious diseases like
neuroscience and others
so after you heard this brief
introduction into the topic of genomics
i would like to pass it on to dr raghav
who will speak about the other sessions
in the program and kind of talk about
more of the practical application of
genomic data analysis in the context of
several different projects
so dr raghav i'll pass it on to you
thank you thank you very much elia
let me
let me find ways to share my screen
i think you all can see my screen so
before uh continuing on the same level
let me introduce myself
i am raghavendran i'm a research
consultant and mentor with pine biotech
and omix logics i'm trained in
bioinformatics and i hold a
computational biology phd from max
planck institute so my research interest
in focus is on data science techniques
such as machine learning and deep
learning applied to integration of
multi-omics data like genomics data like
transcriptomics data and like
epigenomics data etc so my role in pine
biotech includes developing curricula
mentoring students in the research
fellowship program etc so for my
research projects i leveraged a lot of
publicly available data to infer very
relevant biological research questions
so please let me talk about one such
example in a very brief a couple of
slides where i developed machine
learning models to predict a tumor
response for a variety of treatment
options
employing multi-omics integration of
transcriptomics data and genomics data
and copy number variation data so i
don't need to introduce you to the
adverse effects of cancer as we all know
cancer is the leading cause of deaths
worldwide so for such a dreadful disease
that we have known for a long time the
systematic cancer treatments have relied
on
using chemotherapeutic drugs that are
basically marginally more toxic to
cancer cells than
normal cells this is a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond
positively to cancer drugs but in
comparison about 80 percentage of the
patients respond positively to popular
painkillers that are available in the
market so one prominent solution to this
problem is to employ
something technically known as precision
oncological therapy where a treatment
strategy for cancers
designed by targeting molecular
characteristics of the patient's tumor
so hence the treatment is personalized
to the patients
who are likely to respond to specific
cancer therapies there is not
sufficiently enough data from cancer
patients and not uniform data from
cancer patients to molecularly
characterize the tumors that we have
that we have underhand under multitude
of different treatment options that is
being currently studied in different
clinical trial levels so we have to
resort to a suitable model systems so
one of the suitable model systems is the
immunocompromised
mouse model which is also known as
patient-derived xenografts this is done
uh by by transferring the tumor cells
from the cancer patients and before
transferring the tumor cells into the
mouse models
we subject those tumor cells to next-gen
sequencing techniques and gather
information regarding genomic data
regarding transcriptomic data regarding
epigenomics data and regarding copy
member variation and other omics that
are currently under study so once these
tumor grafts or tumor cells are
translated or sorry transferred into
mouse models then
these mouse models can be subjected to
subjected to multiple treatment options
or administered several cancer drugs
that are currently under clinical trials
and study
to understand the effect of these drugs
and to understand the tumors response to
the respective drugs so this study
actually documents
the response of
tumor
breast cancer tumor and breast cancer
and colorectal cancer and other cancers
to multitude of treatment options
and have published this uh research and
this uh and let the
data been
available publicly so this is done by
novartis and the
library and the data that they uh that
they that they have deposited and uh
and is available freely is called
novartis patient derived xenografts
library or encyclopedia so this
encyclopedia or this this library has
both the molecular characterization data
of the tumor and treatment response that
are available along yeah that are
available in the big repositories so
this is a huge amount of data and so
much of data such a wealth of
information in the data generates a lot
of research questions and many many
research questions have explored this
data for specific purposes so my
interest was to use this data to design
and implement interpretable machine
learning models to predict tumor
response to different treatments so
in order to do this since we have
multiple biomarkers since we have
multiple
omics data available so i had to employ
a multi-omics integration at a different
level so generally multi-omics
integration can be applied at um applied
at different levels like as early as
possible or as late as possible
depending upon the complexity and
depending upon the uh depending upon the
uh um
appropriate strategy that will help us
discover complementary information and
uh
maximize the information content
available in this multimix data so for
this particular data i had to include or
i had to integrate it at the late level
because of the
different distributions of the data
along the uh multiple omics level uh
profiling so what did we find after uh
using this multiplex data to build the
machine learning model so before before
the analysis i will just try to tell
that accuracy metrics that are used to
validate the prediction accuracy of the
machine learning model that trains uh
trained with this multi-omics data and
tries to predict the tumor response
based on the separate test data that is
uh separately uh yeah
left over or
separated
so the the accuracy matrix is matthew's
condition coefficient which goes from
minus one to plus one where the plus one
would this plus one would describe
an absolutely
perfect prediction accuracy for the
model and minus one would describe a
completely negative or completely
inaccurate prediction accuracy of the
model and anywhere between zero is going
to describe a random prediction accuracy
and
for the machine learning model that i
have developed so traditionally for
these questions or for understanding the
treatment responses people have looked
into the single gene biomarkers that
characterizes the onset of cancer and
they have tried to find out whether
these single gene biomarkers can also be
employed to predict treatment response
but we found out this is not a very
accurate model as you can see from the
graph when i use the traditional single
gene biomarkers that characterizes uh
this breast cancer level at a different
from different publication for these
different treatment options i see that
their prediction accuracies are not very
great but the moment that i include not
single gene biomarkers but information
from all of the genes
genomic information from all of the
genes i see that that prediction
accuracy slowly start to get better and
i also see that from the precision of
the prediction accuracy that is plotted
for for all the tumor for all the
treatment options that is given in this
box plot so
the the availability of multi-omics
generally
yeah requires
as i mentioned very complex integration
of this data to make sense so here
increasing the uh increasing the
information content by including
multiple omics data we can see that
the
accuracy of the machine learning model
that trained from this data generally
increased towards or everything is going
into a
plus one uh and and everything has a lot
of very good precision in terms of uh
their prediction um
spread so
this clearly tells us that there is a
lot of promise in using this multimix
data to predict the treatment response
using these mouse model systems one two
this also tells us by increasing the
information content one by including
one not a single gene instead of a
single gene markers by including
many more genomic
information and many more multi-omics
information we can increase the accuracy
of the machine learning model that
predicts the tumor response by learning
from the distribution of this machine
learning from this multi-mix data and
and three we can maybe probably extend
this analysis uh to a patient cohort or
patient information that we can
download from tcga repository just to
test uh just to
investigate how a model that is
developed and that is trained using
multi-omics data that is generated from
mouse models can uh or respond to
patient data from tcga repository so
what more could be done i mean
from these results we we obtained a list
of informative genes that are currently
being investigated for identifying
specific biomarker set of genes that can
define or that can
that can um that can be inferred in a
mechanistic detail about the tumor
response to different treatment levels
so
such i mean such uh
i mean these
research projects and these questions
can can be uh very i mean can be
performed uh by using publicly available
data and by using methodologies that are
not completely different from what you
are going to learn
throughout this program and throughout
the
process of uh
done throughout the uh
lessons that are covered in learnomics
platform so we uh using the resources in
omixlogic platform will demonstrate you
how to perform such powerful impactful
research and
by using or by accessing uh publicly
available data so as you have been
briefed before
[Music]
the resources in this platform in the
omixlogic platform and in this program
in this genomic program is aimed at
introducing you to omics data and their
relevant analysis and this will
eventually help you
create or understand
or ask a highly impactful biological
research question that
you can start to explore on your own so
we will demonstrate you uh over the
course of this program how to perform
such high quality analysis on genomics
data we will also show you how example
projects that we have developed which
start from the first base of formulating
a hypothesis or exploring a data
designing appropriate analysis methods
and to perform complex analysis and in
the end interpret the results in the in
a
biologically meaningful way so as you
have always all been
briefed about the ngs
generate large volume of raw sequence
data so to analyze such a raw data many
different tools for genomic data
analysis are used and these include
yeah these include alignment of reads
and full sequences analysis of
relationships between these sequences
and their evolutionary divergence
measurements of the gene expression and
the relationships between
sequences and the relationships between
structures of protein that these gene
sequences encode to as well as
variations or variance in the gene
sequences or the sequences of the genome
that can be termed as somatic or
germline variants using multiple
different calling methods the talbot
bioinfo platform is an example of a big
data platform that can be
used or that can be leveraged to perform
all these analysis and many others using
an intuitively user friendly way so when
the analysis is performed using a raw
data which is usually stored in fastq
file format there are several important
steps to consider such as
pre-processing and mapping variant
calling annotation and uh
other associated steps also so for all
for all these steps and each and every
step we have at our hand a multitude of
algorithm that are available which does
basically a similar job but with a
slightly different uh
manner and slightly different protocol
so
in this program we will teach you or we
will let
we will help you learn how to use this
pipeline and how to use different
algorithms that will suit the data or
that will suit the question that we have
currently in our hand so for
each task you can connect the analysis
jobs into pipeline and each one of these
uh analysis pipeline will uh will
include various inputs and will have
various outputs output
that are that yeah that you can download
and use it for downstream analysis
sometimes
when sometimes for the outputs it is
just sufficient to visualize the first q
alignment files to a reference geom
sequence to quickly get a sense of major
variance or to quickly get a sense of
how our alignment uh varies across the
reference genome one and what are the
different mutant variants that we can
observe and that we can find that are
distributed along the different genes
and different parts of the
genome so this is this is specifically
true or this is especially true when you
have a short sequence or when you have a
targeted regions that are sequenced and
these are very easy to explore but
however to explore a long whole genome
sequences and to visualize that and to
visually interpret that are extremely
difficult so a computational
interpretation and a computational
analysis is performed in addition to the
visualization that we can
that we can use where this computational
analysis
can call the differences in the
first q read files to the reference zero
these are called variants and these
variants
are called from many reads and in the
case somatic in the case of symmetric
mutations in cancer that might include
downstream annotation of found variance
based on the reference database so these
variants can include mutations at
different of different kind and for each
one of these kind you will have
explanation on how to interpret those
different mutations and variants
that are explained in the following ah
that are explained in the following
sessions in this program so
to visualize the uh
to visualize
the alignment of the first q files to
the reference genome we will use open
source applications and we will use
starboard bioinfo platform also to
visualize and to learn about
their
mapping onto the different parts of the
genome so large peaks here i mean this
is the reference genome that is that is
in the gray area and where it has been
so far zoomed out that we cannot read
the
individual nucleotides as uh yeah as you
have seen
that constitutes this genome and these
gray peaks large peaks indicate high
coverage in these areas and low shallow
peaks will indicate a low coverage or
low confidence in alignment as you can
see straight away from the gaps in the
reef that will not that did not cover
these areas and these
these vertical lines in purple or
pink lines will will tell you whether
what are the differences that we observe
at different points in the uh
in our sequence that are aligned to this
reference and in with respect to the
reference so such visual representation
and such visual analysis as i mentioned
might be sufficient for genomes of small
sequences
of
or of targeted sequence
experiments but when you are going to
perform such an analysis for
3.2 billion base pairs it is going to be
extremely exhausting that is going to be
very heavy in for the computer to also
uh work so that's why
multiple downstream variant calling
methods and multiple downstream analysis
methods are employed to analytically
quantify the variance
we we observe in our
mapped sequence with respect to the
reference sequence so a zoomed in
version of these variations or these
visualizations often include
visualizing visualizing in terms of
sequence alignment so these sequence
elements can refer to
excuse me two types of alignment the one
it can refer it can refer or it can be
aligned
to a reference or which is called a
mapping such as when you have a fast q
files as i have mentioned from a sample
and you wish to align each read to the
best position on the genome to find
whether this pascu files or whether the
sequences in the read or the multiple
reads reveal a variation from the
particular reference and in that case on
another case multiple sequence alignment
this is when you have multiple consensus
sequence that you would like to compare
with each other and to develop an
understanding of similarity among them
or between them so
this this both of these alignment can
also be performed in
in turbot bioinfo platform in many cases
the multiple sequence alignment can be
or is used to find structurally
important variation and it
such an alignment or such an analysis
can also be performed with amino acid
protein sequences that can be
that can be
obtained or that can be elucidated by
just simply translating the gene
sequences uh into their respective amino
acid uh coding uh
sequences this is done by taking the
nucleotide codons as elia has mentioned
and then translating them into
their respective amino acid sequences so
the differences in both
the genome level and specifically at the
amino acid level can often be
visualized and can often be identified
or
can often be visualized on the
three-dimensional structure of the
protein that is encoded by the gene and
the location of this mutation on the
protein structure and their effect on
the function of this protein structure
will enable us to make meaningful
interpretations of the variance we
identified as the result of genomic
analysis pipeline so in another way one
can use genomic analysis is by carrying
out
what what usually is called a
genome-wide association studies so to
carry out the grass or genomic
association study researchers use two
groups of participants people with
disease being studied and similar to
people without the disease
sometimes this can also include certain
variations of the disease or certain
conditions that are being
studied to identify
those genomic areas that are responsible
for this altered state or conditions so
researchers then obtain the dna from the
dna from each participants sequence
their whole genome and then
if certain genetic variations are found
to be significantly more frequent in
people with the disease compared to the
people without the disease as you can
find in some of these plots here
they can often be associated or they can
they are these variations are said to be
associated with the disease these
associated
genetic variations can serve as a
powerful tool or powerful
pointers to the to those regions in
human genome where the the disease
causing problem might reside or they can
be interpreted as
as
very relevant regions that are uh
associated with the disease disease uh
or the altered state that is under
currently understudied so the downstream
analysis of these found mutations
variations these snps and often yeah
these can be represented in or presented
in a very different way depending upon
the purpose of analysis or depending
upon the purpose of the use case i mean
it can it can at its simplest form can
be represented as a table and at its uh
more graphical form it can be
represented as a lollipop plot and along
the gene sequence or it can be
visualized
on the three-dimensional structure of
the protein encoded by the gene of
interest ah and then it can also be
visualized as a
yeah it can be visualized using multiple
different visual forms and can be
visualized
along the pathways to which multiple
genes that are associated with and how
these different mutations are these
different variations in these genes
affect the might affect the pathway that
involve these
genes that are currently under study so
this introductory course uh leads into
multiple courses and projects that can
serve as a springboard into the world of
bioinformatics for all of you the
curriculum for this introduction to
bioformation the curriculum for this
genomics course is carefully planned to
cover a broad overview of different
types of methods to analyze the genomics
data and also to understand how this
variety of methods are used to answer
very relevant biological questions that
are found in research papers involving
genomic data and its interpretation so
to learn more about these analysis
methods and their applications in
various project examples you will often
be referred to associated lessons in the
genomic score series and also in other
courses in the learnomics logic platform
these lessons will include more expanded
overview of the key concepts principles
and examples of genomic data
analysis excuse me
these online courses cover or these
online coursework on our
education portal will provide you with a
introductory materials that have been
used multiple times by thousands of
thousands and thousands of people from
all over the world and they have found
these perspectives very exciting and
each of these courses in the end also
contains quizzes and also contains
assignments that will help you or that
will allow you to see how much you have
learned from uh from this course or
throughout the
throughout your progress through these
different courses and different lessons
so in addition to these courses by
seeing how exposed analyze their data
and how these
impactful research
results are achieved
you can yeah you can start developing a
research question on your own to
identify appropriate type of data and
planning by and also to design your plan
analysis plan so for this purpose uh
we have in our platform have carefully
prepared some exemplar projects that
will use all the skills and all the
knowledge that you have learned to infer
highly impactful biological relevance
and to answer high quality research
questions so these projects include a
variety of data a variety of analysis
methods and ask different questions that
are related to using genomics data and
and to
using multiple different align and
multiple different analysis methods to
infer high quality biological
interpretations so these practical
exercises and exposure to data driven
discovery using real research data will
encourage a critical thinking uh for
most of you and the purpose of doing a
practical assignment on the purpose of
going through these projects that we
have developed
and then
learning along with the projects that we
have developed
will
will help you
will help you gain a deep understanding
of these
multiple genomics
concepts under uh processing and the
analysis pipelines involved with it as
well as you can also showcase how
various methods of analysis are applied
in real-world situations so in the end
by following through these example
projects and by also going over the
course 9 which will help you in
designing your own research projects
based on the theme of genomics data or
based on the theme of based on the
research area of interest you can
actually
perform or you can perform a project on
your own you can perform a research
project research you can answer research
question on your own and you can
have
your own research experience that is
satisfying uh
uh
for
for
satisfying for applying various skills
that you have learnt in this course so
far uh
so that will
yeah that will conclude my
uh
presentation i will take some questions
if you have any and if you have not i
can hand it over back to sanalika
okay i have have specific questions
[Music]
using multi-omics data how can you
exclude exclude experimental errors uh
i mean yeah if you use multi-omics data
we can actually normalize these
multi-omics information data using
z-score normalization and we can
probably look for this data distribution
uh by different normalization methods
and different
log transformation methods and then
maybe we can exclude experimental errors
in fastqc
when
first qc2 we can perform the annotation
you will have your answers uh you will
have how to analyze fast queue
uh files and first qc quality check how
to interpret the results in the further
sessions in this genomics lessons
highest channel okay okay i will i will
hand it over now to a spurs and then we
can yeah we can go ahead with the uh
maybe the session we have at our hand
thank you so much
thank you sir
now i would like to share my screen once
again and uh take you all through the
registration uh steps
so this is for them those who have not
yet registered for the program
and uh suganya will be able to share
with you the recording also we are live
on youtube right now so you can follow
the link and go through the session from
the beginning and let and let us know if
you have any questions and we'll be able
to assist you with the same
okay so uh this is the program page
again back to it for the steps to
register yourself for the program
now once you are on the program page
uh for those who would like to register
themselves for the program this the
first session of the program was an open
session for everyone uh for the interest
candidates as well so that you could
join and uh see how this online training
program is going to work and from second
session onwards the enrollments will be
able to join and proceed further
so when you scroll down on the program
page you'll find three subscription
levels
the first one is a beginner one the
second is intermediate and the third one
says advanced
now these three subscription levels are
going to give you the access to the
various resources and different
resources
the in the beginner subscription level
you will be able to be a part of the
live group sessions in the intermediate
one you will also get one-on-one mentor
support and the advanced subscription
level will give you some extra time a
month to work on your research project
so after the program gets completed
after the particular training program
you will be
proposing your research question and
then you will be working on a research
uh problem with the mentor
so these are the three different
subscription levels that you can pick
based on your requirement and get
started with the genomics data analysis
program
if you have any questions please put
them in the chat box so that we can
answer
and i'm also putting in our mail address
that is marketing at omixlogic.com
if you have any questions please reach
out to us on our mail address and we'll
be able to
assist you accordingly also please make
sure that you have added this mail
address to your address book because
many times the mails drop in the
promotions
tab
because of a lot of interactions taking
place between us and the interested
program participants
also i'll uh like to share one more
insights for inside for the
people who have registered themselves
for the program
how are we going to communicate the
answer is slack so this is how the slack
channel looks like and the register and
participants would have received an
invitation mail from me on the uh slack
channel group for the slide channel
group on their gmail accounts so please
accept that invitation and accepting
that invitation will redirect you to
this group and in this group i'm going
to post in
the session details the meeting ids also
i'll be posting in the session
recordings after each session commences
and also we have our mentor here in the
group itself so you'll be able to take
your questions in the group here and the
mentors will be able to assist you
accordingly
i just slack sugar now
only the program in
participants will be able to join this
particular group and i have sent out the
invitation so then i'm not sure if you
have if you have received your
registration so please uh reach out to
marketing answer omnislogic.com and
they'll help you with the um slack
channel links for you to join
thank you
and do we have any other questions if
not then i believe we are good to go and
we will be now meeting in
the second session
okay so i'm taking that as no that we
have no other questions so it was very
nice to have you all with us for the
first session and looking forward to
meet you all in the second uh session
now i'll just share the recording of the
first session with you all so that you
can go through uh the concepts if you
missed any